Corey asks what have you found is the
best way to introduce non wine drinkers
to wine without it seeming overwhelming
chorea Corey I took this question
because not only for the wine people
listening but for the business people
that are trying to educate about social
media or apps or tech culture it's the
same game why did I / index in the wine
world and why do I think I / index in
the business marketing operation social
media marketing world ice marketing
twice because it's so nice it's because
I talk to people not down to them how do
you get people into your thing how do
you do that you talk to them to them not
down to them and that's what I'm really
that's the struggle for everybody who
gets any level of expertise they get
this expertise and they want to leverage
it against their audience to establish
on here you're here I fully believe and
I can I can guarantee the comments
coming right now that one of the reasons
people watch and listen to this show and
have followed me for the last seven
years when I was educating about wine
intimidating subject or social media new
intimidating subject to a lot of people
is I'm talking level set right I'm not
imposing my expertise I'm not making
anybody feel bad that they don't know as
much as me snickering like how could you
ask me this question Ricky I don't do
that right I understand that there's 99%
of the world that I know jack crap about
I know my couple little things and when
I'm trying to learn about other things
from other people that know it's nice to
be talked to at that level which is
respect as a human being not being
imposed on something you learned a
little bit more about and so you want to
get people into wine or anything else
for all of you that are watching and I
see a lot of you who are watching trying
to impose your expertise on food or pets
or anything of that nature I highly
recommend you start realizing you're
talking to somebody not down to them oh
crap wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe